this is the theme the deegeu bismillah
hamdulillah Salam alaykoum greens a
peace thank you for tuning in to the d
show we have two special guests tonight
on the Deen show or today whenever
you're watching us some people buy the
day by the night but our next guests
young brothers who are overcoming many
of the challenges that are out there
that the youth are facing so we want to
get some of their experience share some
of their experiences so insha'Allah God
willing those who are struggling with
the many challenges of life they can
benefit and hopefully change life their
lives for the better be right back for
our special guests here on the Deen show
this is the Deen the deegeu this is the
things the teacher
this is the venue this is the days of
the Bijou
this is the Salam aleikum peace be unto
you welcome welcome
duce yourselves we're here in Dallas
Texas and for our viewing audience your
names are
my name is a fatty fatty suffragette I'm
from Bosnia and just like Eddie just
thought I'd throw that out there mm-hmm
my name is Ali Mahmoud I was born and
raised in Dallas Texas but my parents
are from Egypt so tell us love about so
you you're actually your Hafez of Quran
yeah um Allah from a very young age my
mom put me into a full-time school when
I was about nine years old to memorize
the Quran and Hamza I completed
memorizing the Quran when I was around
12 or 13 and homeless ever since I've
been reciting the Quran reading the
Quran and it's a great passion of mine
Handler what what inspired you what
motivated you to really take it that far
in the beginning I was a nine-year-old
kid so a nine-year-old kid doesn't
really motivate himself to go memorize
the Quran because you know I still
remember the day my mom you know she
told me she's like you know you can go
try it out for one day if you don't like
it you don't have to go if you like it
you can go and obviously as a
nine-year-old I didn't like sitting down
reading a book all day from morning to 7
o'clock in the evening so I told my mom
I don't want to go and so my mom wakes
me up the next morning and she's like
you're getting late for class and I told
her I thought I don't have to go and she
says no you have to go and she made me
go like the option wasn't there so in
the beginning I didn't want to do it
myself
and as I grew up and after I finished
memorizing the Quran I started seeing
the benefits of having it memorized and
I started seeing what the Quran really
is as a book and as a miracle for our
religion why why is it a miracle right I
went and hamdullah and I got to study
with the Sunnah monahon at the Boehner
campus and I got to spend some time with
him for a year you know studying Arabic
and studying the put on and listening to
him speak about the Quran and
subhanAllah that was something that
changed me because I was finally able to
understand what Devon is about and the
thing that I hadn't memorized
I finally had some meaning to me you
know it had the power to move me to
change me to influence my life because I
finally was able to understand it what I
memorized what's being told to me what
I'm supposed to do and what I'm supposed
to do with other people and I haven't
led that you know that helped me out a
lot and the Quran you know has been an
inspiration for me ever you know ever
since I was a little kid Ali tell us a
little bit more about yourself now so
you're also you're a pre-med student is
that right yeah I'm studying biology at
the University of Texas at Dallas the
reason why I'm on the stage because I
like to do Islamic work and from the
love and helping out with the Deen show
when I came to Dallas but one of the
things I wanted to mention was kind of
what my work is help me understand about
myself so when I was in high school I
started the show called press play play
know playing on being the name of the
high school that I went to and on the
show I interview Muslim and non-muslim
students I went to a public school about
basic ethical issues that we have
nowadays you know wasting time and drugs
and promiscuity and things like that and
after doing the show I realized that you
know there's a lot more there's a lot
more things that unite us then things
that take us away and there's a lot of
that natural fit about that natural
state that kind of we were born in that
people kind of drive towards that
goodness and there's a lot of people
young people out there high school
college-age that when they wake up in
the morning they have to put on a mask
because when they go to bed they aren't
feeling too well about their life
they're feeling lost or feeling confused
because of the influences that are going
towards them you know whether it's from
the media or the radio or whatever it is
and so they wake up in the morning and
they have to put on the
masks with their friends just to make
sure that they feel good at that they
fit in and and they don't understand who
they really are
and so I have to be grateful for what I
have because Islam was something that
that helped me understand who I was it
was I took something that I love which
was making videos and and I made it into
something that can help benefit my
society and benefit my community so I
made it into something where I could ask
his questions and kind of give them
solutions to their problems and so you
know slowly that they start to
understand that you know when Pepsi says
live for now that Pepsi isn't looking
out for them they're looking out for
themselves or when easy or sleazy or
whoever gives them what kind of message
on whatever thing it is that they're not
really looking out for them they're
trying to do whatever it takes to make
to give them money and they're slowly
finding out that these messages that
they're getting they're not helping them
out and so it hundred that like it was
it was about the mercy and by the grace
of God when we praise him for what he's
guided us to I was able to carry out
that show and interview those students
on those things and I continued it in
college as well and I found it something
that's really beneficial not only for
for my community but also for myself
it's helped me understand through this
experience of understood you know what
it really means to be a Muslim and
specifically what it means to be a
Muslim American to know that that Islam
is here not just to help Muslims but
it's here to help everybody it's here to
help you know Muslims non-muslims plants
animals trees it's here to help
everybody and so that's what Islam
brought me to do it helped me take
something that I love and propagate it
towards my community and in return I
humbled I have pleasure with myself and
I understand who I am and what my role
is in my community now somebody's at 16
17 18 19 whatever 24 25 you know the
young Shabaab young women young men and
they listen to you guys is different
than possibly listening to their parents
of course parents are giving them good
advice you know having them connect with
Allah the creator of the heavens and
earth and establish Islam in their life
but now you know what it's sometimes not
cool it's not cool to go ahead and be
religious or be committed to this Deen
but what did you guys did you guys find
that it was cool to be a Muslim it was
cool to do Islam you know for in the
beginning it it was a little difficult
because in order to
really better yourself it your your
crowd your community you know your group
your clique that that has a huge impact
on you so before you can make a change
you have to leave that clique you have
to leave those bad friends that's
something very difficult to do you may
spend some time even you know a little
lonely that's very difficult that's
where parents that's where community
comes in and steps in and provides you
intelligent and they tell you hey I
support you we support you through this
change that you're going through we're
not going to judge you we're not going
to make you feel bad but we're going to
help you get through this change so at
the end of the day you can help others
too and you can help guide others with
what you've done and raise a family and
everything you know so at the beginning
you may be a little difficult no one's
going to say it's easy it's never easy
to change make a big change in your life
so towards the better but towards the
end of the day you know after all is
said and done it was it was difficult
starting it up but after after all set
it done you know there was a mount of
respect that came from that from the
community and we shouldn't do it for the
respect but there's a mount of coolness
there's a mount of swag of respect that
came from the community from the young
people and where they see the show and
they're like man I really respect you
for what you're doing or man this is
good this is a good change from from the
usual you know because in and even even
the rappers and the musicians nowadays
you'll find that some of them have
gotten really popular because they're
they're propagating messages that are
about social ills in our society and
young people are starting to appreciate
that and hamdullah there's you know Evo
can last in a society for only so long
evil can last in a society for only so
long until people start being able to
open their eyes up and realize what how
how many messed up things are going on
at home the less time is here to open up
the blinds and let us see the nude of
what of how things should really be
really exciting listening to the young
talk about these very important issues
have you had some friends that have been
challenged by the many ills of society
and what do you try to how do you how do
you deal with their problems when they
come to you how people come to you and
what do you say to them
growing up I used to always think to
myself you know as a teenager even
before that when I was younger I used to
always think to myself you know we all
as kids as adults this teen
we go to the messages we go to the
mosque we listen to the lectures we
listen to the person telling us do this
in our religion do this you're supposed
to do this you're not supposed to do
this you're supposed to do this and I
came to realize um I knew a lot I knew
that I shouldn't be doing this because
my entire life we all have people around
us telling us what to do and what not to
do so we're very well informed on the
things that we should be doing so I used
to question myself and ask if um I know
that I shouldn't be doing something why
am i doing it you know and so whenever
people come to me for advice the first
thing I tell them is do you really have
that connection with allah subhanho wa
taala do you really have that connection
with your Creator because when I ask
myself that question I came to realize
that myself just like so many other
people and you third kids we're just
born into the religion right we are born
into the religion and it's from a very
young age we are told what to do you're
supposed to be praying you're supposed
to be doing this and it's not something
that we came across ourselves right like
a convert if you look at a convert
compared to someone who's born Muslim
they went through that journey they went
on that path and they've explored all
the options so when they finally see
that light at the end of the tunnel they
can actually truly appreciate it because
they've been through that journey
compared to someone else who was just
born into the religion and it's not
something that they wanted to do it was
just because around them that as fear
people are telling them do this and do
that so I the first thing I tell people
is actually go connect with your
religion for real go figure out what
your religion is about go study the plan
right Allah subhana without and this is
what I was saying you know earlier you
know um when you study the plan it will
actually impact you Olas Muhammad Allah
says Allah I don't know what I can
number one right do they not think that
they're going to be resurrected and this
is a question I always tell people to
ask themselves do you really not think
you're going to be resurrected and when
I say that if I told you right now in
the next five minutes if you were to
walk out that door something really bad
will happen to you like really bad if
you believe me if you honestly believe
that something bad would happen you
would not walk out that door but if you
thought I was incapable of making
something bad happen or if you thought
that you know he's
joking then you're going to walk out
that door so when someone claims to
believe in the religion its if you
actually believe in the religion then
when allah subhanho wa taala tells us to
do something when God tells us to do
something we're not going to do it if
it's bad we're not going to do it if
it's good we're going to do it you know
so I tell people establish that
connection go explore the religion
yourself go find that thing that
connects you to a las plantas
go find that thing that connects you to
the religion because if unless you have
that you can get the message people can
tell you everyday if you know for the
rest of your life to do something but
you're going to just completely ignore
it it's not going to have any impact on
you you have to find that connection
with the religion and the Creator so
that when his words reach you they
actually impact you and change you and
influence your life and you know move
you in a way where you become a
different person we're going to take a
break we're right back with more here on
a Deen show do you think these things
are going to bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain think you're happy you're
kidding yourself is really awesome what
we are offering in Islam what we have
found in Islam for ourselves is a means
by which our hearts are in peace they're
at rest they're not discontent we are
pleased with what we have
those who do I am Not Afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid to stand alone
if Allah I am Not Afraid to stand alone
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid to stand back here on the Deen
show and we're doing a live show in
Texas Dallas and we're with the young
bucks the young brothers and they've
established this Deen this way of life
the way of life that's pleasing to the
crater and have you guys looked at some
of the evidence that Islam provides to
the human being to be convinced that
this is indeed not from any human being
but this is indeed from the creator of
the heavens that Irvan share that what
really overtook you and really
captivated you from these evidences that
Allah is talking about who wants go
first um a loss of hundreds Allah he
says in the Quran and one eye he says
are the blemish upon Oh James McMahon
are him yeah anyone let me know Karen
was John Harbaugh become - hi Lana
don't fool me hoon Allah Subhanahu WA
Ta'ala says o you who have believed and
this is one of my favorite eyes when I
was studying it with my teacher in
Dallas this was one of the items that
had the biggest effect on me Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala says o you who have
believed and in this ayah he's giving us
a recipe for success in our lives what
we're supposed to be doing he says o you
who have believed right Doodle Corps
prostrate to your Lord do such that yeah
I let in animal care Western why our
Buddha become worship your Lord well
founded light lined up into for the home
and do good so that you may be
successful and when you just listen to
the translation if this ayah you think
it's just you know go pray to good
worship your Lord so that you may be
successful but allah subhanho wa taala
teaches us so many lessons in this one
ayah that we don't see when we just look
at it the first thing that he tells us
is oh you who have believed in the past
tense right so he's trying to teach us
and he's talking to the believers so
he's telling the people you know he's
teaching us that you might believe but
that doesn't mean you know you're
perfect that there's no flaws that you
still don't have something to work on
you can say I believe but then there's
still a lot of stuff that you need to do
to work on yourself so yeah even Lavina
album then he tells us to do little core
and then he tells us to do such and if
you know how Muslims pray those are the
different steps of our prayer and what
my teacher pointed out to me in this
ayah is one of the first things allah
subhanho wa taala teaches us is how to
submit to him right the first step of
submission when you do little core when
you're bending over you're submitting
yourself to allah subhanho wa taala
right in that position when you're
praying you could be the biggest guy you
can be really tough you know if a little
baby comes and pushes you while you're
praying you're going to topple over
right and then after that he tells us to
do sub step and that is a call to
conform submission when a person puts
their forehead on the ground in front of
the Creator or anyone that is the
ultimate form of submission and no
matter what time you come from right and
then after that Allah subhanAllah
teaches us once you fully submitted
yourself to me right once you fully
completely submitted yourself to me
that's when you're ready to do what
wardrobe welcome that's when you're
ready to actually
worship because until you submit to me
you're not ready to worship and then
right after that Allah Subhanahu WA
Ta'ala says why would Allah become what
Harlan claim and then do good to other
people so that you may be successful so
he mentions doing good to other people
after he says worship me because until
you do allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala justice
until you give him all his due rights
because his own that has given us the
most right no one has given us more than
Allah Subhan Allah tada
so until we give him everything that we
own him how are we expected to go around
and do good for other people when we
can't even do good for our own selves
and and just in this just in the word
structure that Allah sucanat out of the
way he places his words he teaches these
these lessons right and in the ends that
ayah by saying so that you may be
successful and this is the end of surah
Hajj the second last ayah the next surah
immediately after this what sort of
moving on but element you know that's
how the solar starts but after I had
known I live in a home facility in [ __ ]
all right allah subhanaw taala starts an
extra by saying surely these people have
attained success in the first part that
we were talking about he's telling us
how to attain it what to do the recipe
and then in the next Allah immediately
he tells us these people had attained
success the beginning of salaam openly
and he tells us all over their qualities
right but something outside forgot to
mention was in the first ayah Allah so
Allah says yet adenine Ankara was to do
right here he tells us to do little cool
and Sasha which is basically to
prostrate towards him and then he tells
us right afterwards to worship Him now
you might think it's kind of redundant
right if I tell you go pray or go
worship it's one in the same for us
right go worship or go pray why are you
repeating the same thing because we
considered the same thing but allah
subhanho wa taala god right here what he
does is he highlights prayer he mentions
at first before anything else right
having that connection because we had
she helped the Nasir you know he was
telling us earlier one of the other
episodes how important prayer actually
is right and we learned that another
prophesy some said a woman has over here
are beyond my family Allah for in solo
Han Solo has died Armand were infested
at facility which basically means the
first thing that we're going to be held
accountable for in the day of judgment
is
prayer fr prayer is good and solid and
everything else will be good but if our
prayer is bad then everything else would
be bad as well ring crow exactly so
that's why Allah cement that starts off
I think before you worship me before you
want to go out and do all these millions
of things that you have you know written
down on the list make sure you observe
in your prayer that's the most important
part right and when you look at this and
the way all those behind what are that
you know talks to us in the Quran and
this is saying to your question when you
look at the front and open it which I
suggest everyone should do you open the
book and it's as if the person knows you
right it's someone it's reading your
heart it's talking directly to you just
like you know someone if I created a
product and tablet an iPhone whatever
I'm like I'm never going to make one but
if I did I would know how it works
because I created it right the Creator
always knows best about his creations
so I'll blossom or tada in his book he's
giving us a guide a manual to our lives
and when you read it it affects you and
it shows you that this is the only true
religion because there's no one else I
can know you better than God and it's
proof in the book that he's actually
there and that he's actually our garden
that he created us because he knows us
better than anyone else
Holly tell us what are some of the
social pressures that you've seen some
past friends some friends that you know
of today that are going to some of the
struggles some of the hardships and how
do you feel because you've overcome a
lot of these what advice would you have
for those who are struggling with drugs
or promiscuity and all the other evil
vices that are out there
I'm the at the end of the day you have
to realize that it all boils down to
worshiping your Creator and society's
telling us to worship all these other
things you know the music's telling us
to worship this commercials are telling
us to worship that people worship their
bank accounts they worship their cars
and worship girls and worship money etc
they worship all these things fashion
designs and things like that and people
think that's all good when things are
okay but when hardship comes into our
life that's when they really truly
realize how weak and how feeble we are
you know take away oxygen from somebody
for three minutes they're done that's it
we have to realize how thankful we need
to be for what we have and so when you
realize what kind of position were in
that we're more of a
better position to be a slave than
anything else to be a slave to this
creator when you understand that and
really internalize that life becomes
pretty easy because all you know that
your only job to do is you have to
please your Creator and like brother
father said when you open up that put on
and you realize how easy it is to prison
please your Creator how open arms he is
to take you in how when you take one
step towards him he run towards you when
you realize how easy that is and how
forgiving is that when you make a
mistake and a loss Montella forgives you
he doesn't only just cover up that
mistake but he turns that mistake and he
makes it into like a pile of gold for
you turns it into good deeds for you
when you realize how easy that is your
life becomes a lot easier your life
becomes a lot easier when you realize
that your only job in this life isn't
again a plus because you're studying
really hard is to get an A+ because
you're pleasing the teacher because you
tried your best when you realize that
your job in life is to try your best
that's when things become a lot easier
but here that nowadays we have kids who
are especially the weed epidemic man
it's crazy you know it's health health
issues aside whatever the health debate
goes it doesn't matter the the problem
is that people if you put up on Facebook
an issue about how weed is unhealthy I
guarantee you you'll have at least
twenty people or something who think
they're professionals in the subject
we'll post a bunch of articles and a
bunch of stuff that who knows where the
informations come from arguing about
that right you put up a tweet on
Facebook everyone's going to argue about
it and you know the scariest thing about
that is is that people are so passionate
about it the young people they get so
passionate they're so sincere they
really want to prove to you that we it's
okay and it's not like they did the
research beforehand like I'm gonna make
sure this is okay for me and then I'm
gonna start doing it it's because
they're doing it and they feel bad with
themselves you know that's what that's
that's the unfortunate reality nowadays
instead of spending their time towards
doing good things productive things in
life instead of researching real things
in life you know doing well in school
doing well for society researching
important things instead of doing that
they're researching things to make
themselves not feel bad well I got a
proposal for you give up all that stuff
submit yourself to the will of God and
you'll find happiness and no other way
then anything else can offer you because
at the end of the day you get something
you always want more you get some weight
you want more you get some drugs you
want harder drugs you get a girl you
want a nicer girl you get a car you want
a nicer car you get a house or in a
nicer house you see the person billion
is your house next you want that house
at the end of the day all
comes down being pleased with yourself
and you can't be pleased with yourself
unless you're unless a law is pleased
with you you got to follow what he does
beautiful advice beautiful advice we'll
be back with some more of our brothers
here the young bucks giving all those
out there of our viewers all over the
globe some wonderful advice be right
back in Paradise there's no death yeah
you know there's no sickness no sickness
in a world of peace and tranquility no
Wars no fighting no fighting anything
that you want yeah never you can have it
yeah
in the end of paradise yeah and God
wants us to have that but the price we
have to pay is give up
gah
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here are just not
anyone's job to go into someone's heart
to change their heart your job is to
topi what the truth is and the alley of
it is while we're sitting here while I'm
sitting here constantly paying for the
disease the kill was free back here on
the Dean show and we're talking about
real issues that are on the minds of the
youth some have not corrected their
behavior and it is just progressing
towards the worst so we end up following
our desires we go down a dead-end each
and every time so let's try to give some
kind of live situation that let's say
happen or has happen or let's say it
happened to you you get a call from a
family member and it's your first cousin
and she's like hearing that you memorize
the car on and man you've changed your
life around and she's like miserable and
she's like this guy's broke my heart and
I don't know what to do and I'm sick of
the club help me give me some advice
what would you tell her the first thing
that I would you know I would have to
say is that the clubs and you know the
guys and the heartbreaks and everything
that you're going through it's because
you know allah subhanho wa taala our
creator he gave us a lifetime he told us
what to do he gave us you know goals and
what he expects from us right so the
moment you know you call about these
things you already know that you're
headed in a wrong direction that's
obviously not the right way right if
you're feeling a certain way if you're
calling me because you know you're
feeling horrible you're feeling bad
you're feeling sad obviously those
things that you thought we're going to
make you
we aren't making you happy right because
when you went into that relationship you
did not go into that relationship to get
your heart broken you went into that
relationship you know because you
thought it was going to be good right
when you went clubbing you didn't go
clubbing because you're like I'm gonna
go so I can get sick of it tonight you
went because you said I'm gonna have a
good time this is going to be fun you
went in understanding that this is what
life is all about right so when someone
comes up to me and they say you know I'm
having these issues the first thing that
you have to tell them is this is not
what life is all about this is what our
life is about right when our religion
first came to the companions before they
accepted the religion they were clubbing
all right maybe not raves like us today
with disco balls but they had their own
versions you know they were drinking
they were doing a whole bunch of stuff
right and when Allah subhana Matata when
he brought down the religion the first
thing and this is what this is you know
the the the steps that I follow as well
is the first thing that he did before
telling them you know this is wrong this
is right don't do this don't do that he
kind of built this connection with him
you know he said this is what a man is
this is what Hellfire is fearing you
know understand the consequences of your
bad actions and then he also put some
stuff there to motivate us do this
follow this path if you follow this path
you're going to be happy and I guarantee
and here's the proof right and that's
what he did and he built them on that
and because of that and because of that
connection that he built with them by
motivating them with good and you know
telling them that there's going to be a
punishment if they continue doing bad
later on when he told him not to do
something or when he gave him commands
and stuff it was easier for them to
follow because I had to had a connection
with him so then you know the best
advice I can give is build that
connection with allah subhanho wa taala
and understand who he is and you're
going to be happy there's no way you can
be said hamdullah mashallah she's saying
right now just saw Allah Haider she goes
and start the praying she wears that
modest dress the hijab and she gets
connected with the crater last and final
question here before we got to go Danni
is calling you and he remembers all the
good stuff you've been telling them
you've been telling them worship the
creator not the creation you warned
about the Day of Judgment consequences
of your action
but now he's just you know pumped up
with all the dope and the coke and all
these other stuff and he's like man I'm
flipping out man I remember what you
told me but I can't take it you know she
broke my heart I'm gonna commit suicide
I can't take life anymore it's done I'm
gonna leave this world and he called you
because he wanted some final words Oh
bye what would you tell him yeah that
kind of situation the best thing you got
to do is listen you know a lot of people
they don't even need advice I just want
someone to listen to and as Muslims we
need to be compassionate people and
that's the kind of religion that that we
learn that that's the kind of ocean that
it preaches is us to do it has to be
compassionate people to others you know
so when you live for your yourself again
like I said earlier you kind of you want
more you want more want more when you
start living for others that's when you
start you realize you have that self
realization because that's what a lost
month Allah wants us to do a lot wants
us to that's why he put us on this earth
to serve others so when you learn so in
that situation the best thing you would
do is to listen that person if you
obviously become serious you might have
to contact some authorities but other
than that I mean you would listen that
person be there for that person when
they realize that Islam is the thing
that brought you there is that they
realize that Islam is the way you're
acting the way you are because of Islam
then that's that's the kind of way of
life they're gonna want to take I
guarantee you that when they realize how
beautiful Islam really is in practice
and what if you said you know what I
agree and these are the things you were
telling me how can I be a Muslim what I
got to do go to the Deen show check out
the Deen show watch some of the shows
make sure you feel comfortable with it
read some put on contact your local
message and then there's a few steps you
can take to enter Islam it's very simple
it's very easy and then it's not that
you're guided then you're in a better
position to be in guidance you're in a
better position to be in guidance as a
Muslim because it's just it's a lifelong
struggle lifelong struggle of coming
towards o Allah you're a better position
at that point and life's only gonna get
better from then on in may God Almighty
the credit would you guys people thank
you so much thank you for being with us
and thank you for tuning in and
listening to these brothers these dudes
I'm telling you man these guys are cool
and they're on the D on the Deen show
and everything that they are sharing
with you it comes from the Deen from the
authentic knowledge of the Quran
verbatim word of god and the authentic
teachings of the last and final
messenger sent to mankind
mohamad this is Islam they're talking
Islam in reality everything is coming of
goodness from the crater and then live
in his good life in a sharing of you and
you could be living this good life to
just get with the Dean get with the
creator of the heavens and earth ask him
for guidance asking for guidance
continue to tune in every week call us